la principal es este cierre de bares a
partir de este martes además de esto la
prohibición de todo tipo de consumo y de
venta de alcohol en la vía pública y
también de reuniones de más de diez
personas en la vía pública a esto se
suma la prohibición de todo tipo de
ferias de congresos de circos por
espacio de 15 días cierre de gimnasios y
también de piscinas aunque en éstas
todavía podrán ingresar los menores de
edad porque viene un periodo de
vacaciones escolares además de esto hay
también restricciones para visitar a las
personas que estén en residencias de
adultos mayores esto habrá que hacerlo
con cita previa y efectivamente pues en
las universidades donde se está dando el
40 por ciento de los focos de contagio
en toda esta región pues está el aforo
máximo de 50 por ciento que será puede
ser tanto en los comedores como en los
salones de clase